now for some perspective from capitol
hill first on cbs mornings we are joined
by congressman michael mccall the
ranking member of the house foreign
affairs committee congressman good
morning i know that you've been getting
all the latest briefings what is the
newest information that you can share
well we know he uh invaded uh
very strongly uh particularly last night
but the night before uh in eastern
ukraine the three
major deployments were north of kyiv
that have gone down to the capital city
of course uh eastern europe and the dom
boss eastern ukraine uh and then the
crimea sea so we're seeing an air land
and sea attack taking place right now
with artillery
with uh with planes uh dropping bombs
uh missiles and uh also from the black
sea uh destroyers uh showing
you know the coast so this is uh we
haven't seen anything like this since
really since uh hitler invaded poland in
world war ii
i just hope this is not the beginning of
world war iii
we all do congressman is there any
turning back at this point is there a
role for diplomacy or is it too late do
you think diplomacy should be off the
table
well i think yeah i think uh the time
for diplomacy is over
uh i mean uh putin has decided uh to do
a full invasion of the entire country of
ukraine there's a lot of speculation he
would only go so far it's pretty clear
to me that he wants the entire bread
basket of of russia back he's always
wanted ukraine and now he's testing the
current president
with this full-fledged invasion i think
it's important to note to your viewers
that ukraine is not a nato country uh
therefore article 5 does not apply here
uh if they were we would have a
full-fledged uh nato uh war with nato
against russia but we don't have that in
this case however we have provided and
i've signed off on the military weapons
sales to ukraine javelins
ammunitions sniper rifles this is the
beginning of what we're going to see as
a resistance that will take place in
ukraine and let me just say that we
stand strongly with the people of
ukraine
congressman how do you explain why we're
involved in this at all with your
constituents why should americans care
that's a great question why do we care
about ukraine well what is putin trying
to achieve here he's trying to weaken
and and diminish the role of nato
um he wants the control the black sea
for energy purposes um and this also has
a uh
sort of an effect on all of our foreign
nation adversaries uh not only this is
not just by ukraine it's also about
president xi china and taiwan i was just
came back from israel it's about iran
and their nuclear bomb pursuit it's
about kim jong-un and his rockets being
fired
in north korea it's all interconnected
and that's why we have to show strength
here
i think
we have to come together now republicans
and democrats on a very strong sanctions
package the likes of which we've never
seen
all right well congressman mccall thank
you so much